thank you
hello hello
welcome welcome
is the uh the audio okay
hello everyone
good
hey Raptor hey Damion dumb Damien Damien
John hexa
how's everyone doing
I think I'll do flying class hey proxim
hey fudgeon
hey Kyle hey cash hey bryle
hey Edward
how's everyone doing
hey Andrew hey snow
hey shift
hey our menti
how's everyone doing
good good
so apparently I have flying class which
is exciting
um I don't have that many hours I have
two characters and they're kind of both
around the same level so I haven't
really progressed that far
I give
fall from their broom first
hey Deutsch
everybody grab a broom and
from the Philippines
Mr clothing your attention sorry Madame
Kagawa everyone please welcome a new
student to our flying class
the goal of today hey some dude named
him
hey respect
is first and foremost a means of
transportation thank you thank you uh
I'm level 12 on this character
diving what level are you guys will not
class we'll leave that to professional
quickly yeah this is my first
playthrough my second character around
the same level
I've got two characters that are both
the same level and both Southern
very diverse
taking my sweet time and rest your
weight on the seat
hello link stinkus
uh nope both bad
you stupid ratty School broom uh the
intention was one Gryffindor that's good
that's bad but uh that hasn't happened
both bad both children none of that
useless a gust of wind will throw you
right off
hello Liam
[Music]
very nice if you hear my Whistle While
You're In Flight ground yourself at once
[Music]
good now for your first lesson fly
through each ring in the courtyard do
take care the brooms are school property
is One Piece
hey hey
I think I'm getting the hang of this
first time flying on the Broom
what do you think
[Music]
well done now that you're climatized to
your broom let's see how well you manage
with a more advanced exercise shall we
have nothing
nothing
okay this next set of wins will take you
around the grounds for more of a
challenge
what a view
yeah the Ambiance goes along goes a long
way
[Music]
this reminds me of the tri-wizard
tournament
well our aquatic resident likes to make
an appearance for a little while the
giant squid
[Music]
huh that wasn't too bad thank you Jerry
appreciate that
you're kind
well done
have a moment
what's uh Harry's favorite spell
Expelliarmus or Expelliarmus
I love the game a bit more challenging
but I'm getting ahead of myself we
haven't properly met I'm Everett clopton
am I right and suspecting that a
Slytherin like you might be interested
in making an escape from class
foreign
what did you have in mind a bit of a
detour so to speak
hello Sean
yeah the door is about to begin
now right now hang over the
Transfiguration Courtyard lovely as ever
sir
day
nice to get above it all isn't it
ahead of the garden the hucklepuff
common rule Windows just peek out big
claustrophobic for my taste
how was ever applied so quickly do you
guys think we'll get uh quidditch DLC
helpful if you need to escape a tricky
situation
you sure you're not part hippogriff
I'm from England but I live in Canada
I've got to wash it down English accent
that's the famous bridge
think of all the magic holding it up I
mean look at it
sure isn't it
flying tips and a jaunt around Hogwarts
this is quite the tour Everett
I think they'll get we'll get uh Trail
wizard tournament DLC as well
this concludes our door I live in
Vancouver as well
and go to the van expert today
[Music]
no no no I'm not from Wales
thank you
yes yes
where I have you to be there's a few of
you in here from Vancouver interesting
there's only 65 people in this stream
Hefty
multiple following Minds Vancouver
Mr clockdin I am disappointed in you
you're in this class because you're
still because you're still not showing
yourself or frankly your broom the
proper respect but Professor enough
class is finished for the day
yes yes like hit the like as for you if
you enjoy you do well do you need better
judgment in the
future up
that was some rather good fly
yeah that's Vancouver
sorry about that business with Kagawa
but you have to admit those views were
worth it
I'm gonna do a video on the history of
ilvermorny coming out soon
it was worth losing a few house points
for that detour
seem at home on a broom
and if you had a fancy model you could
fly laps around Imelda she's kagawa's
favorite house of lots of Vancouver
killer a thing or two if I have my own
broom hate having children sorry after
class perhaps off to purchase a broom
then if you can you should
I wish I could I recommend visiting Alby
weeks at spent which is in hogsmeade
he's always looking to test new models
I'll keep an eye out for you in the sky
[Music]
how is everyone
from Vancouver in this chat
a bit confusing
um cursed child
is me I don't have
a strong opinion either way
oh
I appreciate
the attempt
like it as low particularly
some
spell practice
meet me outside the defense against the
dark arts classroom I know a discreet
place near there
what are you up to now let's meet
Sebastian
shalom
who's Parry Pippin
what is this
hmm
should I do this
I might as well
why not right
ASAP please when do I get a broom that I
can just fly around online by myself
please meet me in the seventh floor
Corridor as soon as you can I have an
idea for somewhere you can focus on your
studies away from prying eyes and
distractions inspector patronum I've
always said that
[Music]
Patronus charm
all right
oh can I where in hogsmeade
uh where do I buy it
it's my second character but they're the
same level pretty much
oh nice okay well I'll go buy one
and then
we will fly around five thousand do I
have that
what do I have
how do I
see this
oh okay no I don't have five thousand
oh what do we have here
how do you eat
it's a mistake
nothing the beasts around here
rebellious
thank you thank you thank you thank you
did everyone just rush through the game
or
were you able to enjoy it
third play through are you doing a
different house every character I think
that's
my intention moving forward
thanks Soren
200 hours
damn
I had early access to the game but I had
to go away
so I didn't really
you got bored and stopped playing
no
these walks have seen better days
I'm trying to do as many side quests as
I can and just explore and just enjoy
also I'm bad at the game so that'll slow
things down
you're bored already wow
bye-bye
cool Peter
very nice
I guess I'll buy a broom
as well
while I'm here I come might as well
which shop uh sells brooms
and hogsmeade
Phoenix
called the broom shot
this
oh
is it okay
and I see so it's next to the side quest
potions of a specialty here should you
need any oh this is him
hello Mr Pippin we'll do it after that
delivery yes I do I a capable student
such as yourself should have no trouble
making the trip to Cambridge it's just
something yeah yeah I know I'm just
trying to do the side quest Fatima Wang
ordered a few invisible I used to go
myself constantly if you take this
I'd be happy to help with the delivery
you have no idea how grateful I am truly
here are the invisibility potions you
request she's a talented
okay
okay so where's this uh broom shop
[Music]
here
foreign
snitch
here
oh yeah
done thank you thank you thank you
thank you
very sweet
what kind of videos do you guys want to
see on the channel about the game
ah new face wonderful
hello Mr Wheats is it Alby week's At
Your Service welcome to spin witches
apologies if you came by before and
weren't able to come in Shop's been
closed since trade routes were disrupted
had to travel as far as London to meet
with my supplier and I've only just
returned thankfully with inventory I
presume you're in the market for a new
got a few rare you Weavers available win
wisps too
sounds quite the array of brooms I'll
have a look around thank you
what are we looking for today
it's kind of
up to everyone's interpretation whether
or not as Canon I haven't completed the
game so I can't say for sure yet
but from what I've experienced so far
I'd like to consider it Cannon if
possible
I'm just I would consider myself open to
that at least
but I respect that not everyone will
feel that way
which broom do I get
yeah what's up Cannon
which broom folks
it's amazing the highest quality
no okay well
that awesome is it the highest quality
uh I get this one
you'll be thrilled with that broom I
promise you so I can just use this isn't
it how do I thanks for stopping by well
certainly be a
be at a girl's class they all have their
limitations you seem to be a flyer who
might be interested in say some
enhancement go on
new I think you'll be quite happy with
the performances lower altitudes but you
may not is that speed consistency tends
to falter as you rise I believe I can
remedy this issue I have some ideas for
enchantment what I need is someone as it
happens an ideal situation I could
complete
that sounds intriguing
I'll see what I can do thank you it'll
be
frog
once you've beaten imelda's time be sure
to let me know
okay so I have to leave
enthusiasm
thank you thank you jar jar okay so how
do I use this room
L1
aha
hello fate
this is nice and quick
this is gonna
speed things up
Hello Ghost Rider hey Kratos
um
no I hadn't heard of ancient Magic
prior to Hogwarts Legacy
if it isn't slytherin's newest room
Talent
hello Imelda I'll be weak sent me
did he know still take tried to help him
one
he nitpicked my flying technique and
that was why is he roping caught wind of
you showing
seems someone's jealous she's jealous of
a broom me Southern quidditch Captain
jealous everyone knows that class is
only for but for some reason now people
think your competition perhaps I am you
can't be what passes through Slytherin
enough of this I hold one of the fast
Slytherin
this isn't gonna go well actually why
not I can be I'm so looking oh
foreign
nice nice nice
[Music]
foreign
thank you
don't don't love the controls
success
looks like it
did anyone else see that I didn't do
well but
did it
Ah that's not you must have cheated you
oh
fine you won no it wasn't good don't
think this is over don't lie to me you
can't determine skill from one single
trial surely my win means something
[Music]
I'm glad to hear that James but you're
still going to have to prove yourself if
you want to earn my respect
challenge accepted then perhaps you have
what it takes after don't get your hopes
you can try to
the podium we'll see next time
that is this now
my my I don't think I can do that
'd be glad to hear how I've had
try
this is rather fun
[Music]
you know what
how do I
I messed up how do I exit this
do I have to finish
well now I can't win
absolutely not
[Music]
a castle must have been quite statement
this time
foreign
[Music]
this is
I did what's up for ages
and kind of got the same time
okay I'm gonna go to weeks
yeah
huh
what is it L1 and circle yeah
oh
I think I could be that time
but I don't want to be stuck in
that Quest any longer I don't think it's
even a quest is it
oh
I'm liking the broom I'm liking it
seems all roads lead to hogsmeade
well hello
when do you get the ability to unlock
doors that's my question
oh you're back we've something to report
I hope
Mr wheat I was able to set a record on
my broom incredible Miss Rays must have
been shocked tell me how was the broom a
little turbulent and it's wanting for a
bit of speed but it fed well enough
I will say that it tended to drift a bit
to the left in certain turns I heard us
like swoosh when I dipped ah okay thank
you
that's precisely what I needed to know
drifted eh even the nice size
why would anyone I had a way
I'm excited to him this guy speaks too
much natural feeling about this upgrade
I know how to address the issue of
altitude as it relates to speed the
glasses are ridiculous uh
uh okay where am I going
quests
okay let's find Sebastian
the broom maker looks like James
who who looks like James
hello James
yeah maybe a bit
how was that idea
everything
no no we see you James
foreign
is this Sebastian over here
Sebastian it's been a while it has glad
you received my owl
I have something to show you first let
me thank you for what you did in the
library of course Scribner tried to give
me detention but I well you took the
fall for me did you find what you were
looking for I did
something was missing
I'm not sure here is the best I tested
if you guys enjoy the stream please give
it a like professors know about it thank
you thank you
this way
where are we going revelio has a secret
passage just here
it's well disguised
thank you thank you
how did you find this place
my friend ominous gaunt
he named it the undercroft
we used to play golf zones here all the
time
with my sister
she loved that phone Rebellion oh
I should have sold my stuff
damn
oh
Don't Mind If I Do
foreign
I should tell you I swore to ominous I
would Safeguard this place so please
so annoying when you can't take on any
more care
foreign
Charming house cloak
yeah I know I can change the appearance
but I'm constantly changing gear
it's hard to stick to one thing
I almost don't want to bother changing
it because I'll just switch again soon
I know ominous met him in our common
room
I've noticed he uses his wand to
navigate the castle he does no idea
however
um
because one seems almost sentient not
something
in the four years
regular occurrence his family knew about
it
the gorns are full of secrets I've never
heard anyone else speak of it again
mention this of course
glad you understand anyway
really
like the blast professors say
a proper magical education ought to
include all magic my thoughts exactly
spell like confringo is only truly
dangerous in untrained hands such spells
should be properly to be fair
you should learn it
it may take a while to get the feel for
it mimic by one yeah Merlin was in
Slytherin the incantation is confringer
very well
you're getting it
ready to actually try it out
hello mr489
uh here's confringo
the targets though
best to keep the undercroft intact
have a go at those candelabras both have
their uses but I think you'll find them
nice work
it's a Todd Hall that's it I think I've
got down
let's get us past uh 69 likes guys give
it a like
to say
I enjoyed that the first time ominous
and I practiced confringo we said yeah
the game is worth it for sure I would
have paid to see that I swore we'd never
live it down so this day there's
something about that spell that's
addictive
this is exactly the type of magic I've
been hoping to learn thank you for the
way that came from
when Bratz haven't been here in
summertime I'm sorry about your sister
perhaps when I next had to
just let me know when and I'll meet you
oh she misses Hogwarts we'll meet you a
new student I shall look forward cheers
I'm not sure you said something was
missed I assume it's to do with what you
told me about the poor key nothing gets
passed and yes it is I'm listening
the book I found in the Restricted
Section Kitty
I suppose with both Rookwood and ranrock
spend as much time and remember
when I head to feldcroft I'll send you
an owl
no I don't play a lot of games these
days to be honest
I got a PlayStation 5 specifically for
this game
but it has kind of reignited my
interests
hello Sebastian
wait
you there
I can hear you oh uh hello ominous I was
just heading to our common thank you
thank you guys recognize that voice
you're the new fifth year did you
do undercroft
what did you get in there
I have uh you want
rooms called the undercroft
ah well I was exploring and then
suddenly found myself in a strange
passageway
the result is that I have two characters
that are almost the same anyone with the
same amount of progress will be able to
help you my father is friends with the
Headmaster I'm
you needn't threaten me
and Sebastian is a good friend I don't
need you to tell me about my oldest
friend thank you very much ominous I
just meant
do you think ominous is upset chat
if you think ominous is upset let me
know
level 13.
uh both of them are absolutely spare a
moment I could use your help not proud
of that to speak with me I did
hello I'm Duncan hophouse pleasure to
meet you
I suppose it must seem that way I'm
going to presume your reputation is
being in fact warranted in which case
you are precise you see we were learning
to repel Bogarts
surely you're joking it may seem
irrational to you but my experience with
releasing a video family which will
include ominous regardless of how
reasonable maybe next week to be I'm
beginning to get a reputation as a
coward so
I'm sorry but you have to admit that I
do not have to admit that anyway to make
matters worse I stupidly blurted out but
I must be braver than people think
the hidden yes rumor has it that the
herbology professor before Professor
garlic it supposedly I was hoping you
could say a bit of an
very well if I'm in the area perhaps I
shall take a look you'd be upset I'd
very much
venomous Valor
hidden herbology Corridor I'd better
keep an eye on high places around the
school for zenobia's gobstones
don't know about this gobstones Quest
is that worth it
no yeah
thanks who's Eva
who's ever Latifah
see ya
there's this loading
yeah definitely worth playing through on
all hands
from what I can tell so far
is it Hufflepuff that goes to ask a man
is that the case
accurate
incendio
oh my
I'm in uh Slytherin
these dry Vines are one spark away from
becoming kindling
yeah ominous will be in well maybe not
the next video but he'll be in a video
soon
about the gaunt family and the gaunt
family Origins
apparently yeah you can go to Azkaban
I haven't done it but
this must be the entrance to the hidden
apology Corridor Devil's snare seems to
thrive in darkness
perhaps it doesn't care for light
it's any lumos
um
Rebellion
lumos
now
seems the devil's now was protecting
chest of some kind
oh my goodness
I need to sell this stuff
it's getting ridiculous
yeah you can go to class
burgundy Road
very nice lumos
lumos
I imagine a piece of that enormous
venomous tentacular would be enough for
Duncan to prove his bravery
Rebellion
that was it hmm
it was kind of anticlimactic
expecting more out of that
is going on
Don't Mind If I Do I'd better keep an
eye on high places around the school for
zenobia's gulp stones
which dragons anything to prove my
bravery yet hello Duncan I have the
proof you wanted that's one leaf must be
I appreciate you getting
now that I think about it puff skin
dunking hello Jane okay Lucas you need
to overcome your cowardice you can't
you I'm doing you a favor I don't need
to be stronger you've wasted my
should never have trusted you
[Music]
hey steal
foreign
meet with Professor Weasley
you and I we are the stuff of poems how
loved is the
business
um you know what I'm not very far into
the game
so my thoughts aren't particularly
developed but I do love it so far
I feel like they did a really good job
with this one and that's kind of after a
decade of
pretty much horrible games
yeah I think we'll get the trail wizard
tournament I mean it doesn't that might
interrupt Canon depending on
how it's implemented
yeah first playthrough I have two
characters the same level essentially
Professor Weasley
hmm somewhere away from prying eyes
yeah a movie two decades
there haven't been very many good games
[Music]
beard
see you've wasted no time
[Music]
if a student embodies all of the traits
equally which is what is this place
probably not going to happen
um it's up to their preference most
likely
plan rebellious to you how to find it by
walking past that bit of wall focusing
on what you need but you've managed to
reveal the room on your own
while I'm here we should take advantage
of the moment now where is Deke
and sneaked fast and gone ahead
the house elf I was speaking to in my
classroom your first day thought he
might help you use the room once you
found it
a man
[Music]
chance I'm clumbering over this mess
opportunity to teach you
The Vanishing spell
you can cast evanesco to vanish certain
objects such as these jet I suggest you
practice the wand
uh I don't have a favorite house
personally Blended now
which is even Esco is this it yeah
go on those chairs
excellent work you'll note that you are
now in possession of moonstone we shall
discuss its use
I think my favorite film is
um
Order of the Phoenix
how do I reveal this item
let's move on
revelio
where in Merlin's name is that elf
is that
goodness
my old school back later okay I wondered
where that had got to
can't believe what's everyone's uh
favorite movie
comment give you an opportunity to
explore on your own until we locate Deke
yes professor
won't you keep it down
okay
how do I get this
thanks DH
I hope this isn't as precarious as it
looks as command yeah
and Intruder stop them
or not do you guys prefer um Chris
Columbus or Alfonso Quran
how does anyone other than a house self
manage to get around in here
Rebellion
what was that
was that a golden snitch
revelio
perhaps you should summon your wits and
find out
incendia incendio
what is that music guys
a bit ominous
I hope that how self can find us in here
oh what do we have here
the uh cursed Child movie thing is it's
not real careful unfortunately this this
seems to happen every couple of months
wait right there dick will come to you
some media Outlet will just make up a
GPS
was last here
student
s dick is honored to meet you Deke has
been a friend since I was a second year
we discover
[Music]
I mentioned you today hello hello
of course Professor Weasley
the room of requirement will always be
equipped for this it's on plot deep
scenes to you seem to have my voice is
too low like quiet room of hidden things
oh that explains it then what I need
specifically is where I can catch up on
my schoolwork without well then and like
the Fantastic Beast movies precisely
that they didn't quite hit the mark
but I thought the most recent one was a
step in right direction
gradually improving
it I think I went the rest sort of
yeah I don't know 6.5 for the first two
and then seven for the last one
something like that
yeah it was a shame that again
[Music]
I was hoping for more uh character
development with uh nikini
forward to seeing what you do
can I
uh and it seems the room has provided to
investigate that item description
yeah it's a shame about that in terms of
clothing I like I like depth but I think
mass is doing a good job as well like I
do hope we get more films
the desk will be an invaluable resource
does this identify everything at once
foreign
it's not axed I don't know I don't know
what's happening
you know if they asked it it wouldn't be
at the end of the world I mean they kind
of left it open
um I'm sure they did that intentionally
I'd like them to do Dumbledore and
grindelwald's duel but
yeah I know I can change the appearance
what are you insinuating you don't like
the appearance of my character
I couldn't have chosen this
yeah
yeah it's tough
destroy this
just are you sure about that Horatio
challenging how my character looks
a bit rude
okay guys I think uh I just wanted to
hop on for a little bit but I'm done for
now but I will be back tomorrow
um probably tomorrow night
so I hope
that everyone
has a good rest of the night and I'll
see you tomorrow I'll be posting a video
tomorrow as well
have a good night everyone
bye bye
thank you thank you thanks for tuning in
um yeah maybe like midnight my time
Pacific time
no cursed child isn't gonna happen
no no no I might make a video on it
because I've been asked this question a
lot
okay all right see you guys bye